[Music]
as the summer winds wind down single
tier on that many people are heading to
the beach in california they could have
lots of company in the water
recent drone images from near los
angeles show these juvenile great white
sharks swimming alongside the people
yikes and they've been displaying you
could say some very surprising behavior
carter evans shows us what's been
happening
getting into the water with great white
sharks seems like a terrible idea i
don't dare stand up on this board we're
just off the coast of santa barbara and
within minutes this shark is is so close
i could almost grab its dorsal fin it is
right underneath me now scientists say
that shark is not interested in me or
other people
watch this huge shark swim right up to
these unsuspecting children and simply
turn away the population of these great
whites off socal beaches is exploding i
can only see it now because i'm getting
up high if i were a surfer i'd be lying
down and i'd have no idea it was
underneath me oh my god oh my god don't
bite them
wedding photographer carlos gaona
started capturing these stunning images
off the coast when the pandemic dried up
business almost every time i see an
interaction with a human and a shark
my heart does pound we've all been
conditioned ever since jaws came out to
fear that interaction
but this is far from jaws watch as a
large shark calmly cruises along with
surfers
this one approaches a family a swimmer
is headed right toward another and all
of the sharks seem uninterested despite
the fact that people are out there
thrashing around and their arms are
hanging off boards and legs are hanging
off boards sharks just ignore it chris
lowe is director of the shark lab at cal
state long beach why don't they want to
eat us well we don't really fully know
the answer to that question first of all
we're not close to being on the menu
most of the sharks spotted off southern
california beaches are juvenile great
whites despite their size they're only
up to about six years old and very
inexperienced hunters taking off
lowe's team showed us where the sharks
used the warm coastal water as a nursery
when they're born they're completely on
their own the safest place for them to
be is in shallow water they have to
learn to feed on what's there and the
number one thing that's there are
stingrays carlos's video shows that
they're very aware the surfers are there
yeah in fact we've been able to document
sharks recognizing that somebody's
nearby so they know the sounds of a
person swimming and surfing so they've
learned that we're not a threat
it kind of seems that way but lowe says
that could change if people start going
after the sharks they're a wild animal
and if they feel threatened they will
defend themselves in 2019 the coast
guard had to airlift a surfer who was
bitten by a shark off santa rosa island
but lowe says unprovoked great white
shark attacks around here are extremely
rare i mean we're essentially telling
people here don't worry about the baby
great whites in the water but does the
same thing apply on the east coast
actually no there we have adults that
are there to feed on seals and those
seals are sharing the beach with people
so that's a very different situation
even in northern california i'd be a lot
more hesitant about getting in the water
but off the socal coast this shark is
just swimming so calmly and so
gracefully right now
lowe's team is working to eventually
predict the conditions that would lead
to shark encounters with people i'm kind
of hoping in about five years you'll get
a rip current report and you'll get a
shark report they say these videos and
my interaction are just more examples
that beachgoers and great white sharks
can co-exist at least in southern
california
for cbs this morning carter evans santa
barbara i don't know if i want a shark
report i don't think carter does either
he wasn't really trusting the science
not even a pinky went in the water no he
was on that put one in either great
respect though for sharks you know
they're so vilified but the people that
work with them and know them say they're
really really fantastic great animals
yeah you just want to be left alone
they're stunning creatures but i just
don't want to be there at the moment no
i'm with you i like my limbs